these are Taft Oh as if his they harvest  their powers to the torture of these  Inhumans georgie-boy is gearing up for  war programmable power under our control  No More Heroes entire worlds ooh  terrible danger  time is here I could pull some strings  to spruce up the armory get ourselves  some new toys to play with dangerous  ones  the derivative of Division IV here who  needs their ass kicked  you got to get this bird in the air  before aim comes looking for us  Jarvis is unencrypted in the schematics  and we'll get our tech heads on new gear  ASA  [Music]  [Music]  look at all this which nation state is  aimed ladies were at war with  heroes are people and people don't stop  them it's just one more thing to regret  on my gentleman  as when we got to dance  you want to see powers there we go time  for you  [Music]  those things